buonasera
la mia non è un tentativo di dare una
definizione della intuizione non ne
sarei capace e fini ray da buon avvocato
con il vendervi esclusivamente delle
parole vi propongo viceversa una
intuizione una mia intuizione o forse è
un'intuizione ci sono degli angoli
meravigliosi del nostro paese che sono
insignificanti sconosciuti ai più ma che
per ciascuno di noi significano qualcosa
di speciale questo intervento forse
dovrei dire questa intuizione prestare
al tema di questo the licks è nato in
uno di questi posti
le sorgenti delle capore piccolo angolo
di foresta vicino a roma ma soprattutto
vicino ad una piccola casa nella quale
sono cresciuto e dove ogni tanto torno a
ritemprare il corpo e la mente dallo
stress della professione
l'altro giorno in questo posto speciale
mentre beve un bicchier d'acqua minerale
vedevo la l'acqua che scocciando parte
alla volta di roma per finire nei nostri
nei nostri rubinetti
ho pensato ad una lezione che avevo
fatto qualche giorno prima in università
a proposito del rapporto difficile che
c'è tra la proprietà intellettuale
quella che governa la circolazione dei
film della musica dei libri
dell'informazione e le nuove tecnologie
è stata un'intuizione io credo sia stata
una intuizione la classica lampadina che
si accende sulla testa dei personaggi
dei dei fumetti probabilmente anche chi
di voi è dotato di una immaginazione più
fervida in questo momento si starà
chiedendo cosa c'entra
l'acqua minerale con la proprietà
intellettuale o più semplicemente vi
starete interrogando sullo stato di
salute mentale di chi vi parla è come
dire non posso darvi non posso darvi
torto
vi chiedo 13 minuti o poco più di
fiducia per vedere se questa intuizione
esiste o se è stata un'allucinazione
dovuta comunque all'acqua minerale
per ora mi limito a dichiarare
l'obiettivo è l'obiettivo è quello di
suggerire che esiste una analogia forte
e prepotente tra l'acqua e la
circolazione la distribuzione delle
acque minerali e quella della proprietà
intellettuale e che questa analogia è
così tanto forte che forse i governi e i
regolatori del mondo intero che in
questi anni si stanno interrogando con
insistenza su come si debba fare per
garantire le regole migliori al diritto
d'autore ai brevetti alla proprietà
intellettuale nel mondo di internet non
dovrebbero far nient'altro che ascoltare
la lezione dell'acqua in questo
ragionamento probabilmente va alla pena
come suggerirebbe un buon chimico di
cominciare dagli elementi di lasciare
sullo sfondo le formule ed è quello che
proverò che proverò a fare
l'acqua h2o per chi è innamorato degli
elementi costituisce il 70 per cento del
corpo umano è più o meno la stessa
percentuale dell'intero dell'intero
dell'intero pianeta l'acqua e il
principio di tutte le cose diceva tale
ipad era il sesto secolo avanti cristo
non è esagerato quindi dire che l'acqua
è un elemento essenziale dell'esistenza
umana
io credo che allo stesso modo ci si
possa trovare tutti d'accordo nel dire
che il sapere e le arti la musica i film
il cinema l'informazione il sapere tutto
costituiscono elementi altrettanto
essenziali della esistenza umana
cosa sarebbe la nostra esistenza senza
le idee e senza l'informazione senza
l'ingegno senza la possibilità di
crescere e ascoltando cosa gli altri
hanno da dirci o guardando cosa gli
altri hanno creato attraverso il loro
ingegno a una prima analogia quindi
importante è che l'acqua e le idee
l'acqua e le creazioni intellettuali
sono due elementi essenziali nella
nostra esistenza ma acqua e creazioni
intellettuali
sono hanno molto in più in comune perché
sono entrambe è straordinariamente e
leggere neutre e trasparenti eppure
questa leggerezza questa apparente
neutralità non gli impedisce di essere
forti e travolgenti al tempo stesso
talvolta naturalmente in senso positivo
e talaltra in senso negativo
basti pensare all'effetto positivo di
una pioggia abbondante su un campo arido
e all'apertura di una a scuola in una
zona non civilizzata del paese ma se
voglio guardarla in negativo basta
viceversa pensare alla irruenza è
l'effetto devastante di uno tsunami e
all'effetto altrettanto devastante in
alcuni momenti della nostra storia del
diffondersi di certe ideologie l'acqua
quindi come le idee e l'acqua come la
cultura unisce e divide i e divide i
popoli rende agevoli gli incontri rende
agevoli gli scambi ma nello stesso
momento può dar vita a incredibili
barriere può nutrire come non nutrire
può far crescere o viceversa frenare lo
sviluppo di taluni di taluni di taluni
pensieri di talune di talune idee sin
qui per quanto riguarda gli elementi ma
le analogie le vicinanze concettuali tra
l'acqua e le idee e divengono ancora più
importanti se prendiamo l'acqua le idee
le creazioni intellettuali e le caliamo
in una dimensione è dinamica e invece
non è e non più e non più statica perché
scopriamo così che entrambi gli elementi
sono presenti nell'universo in una
dimensione enorme ma in apparente
contraddizione rispetto a quella che è
una regola economica a portata di
avvocato e cioè quella che è un alta
offerta la presenza di un'altra offerta
dovrebbe rendere basso bassissimo il
valore del bene viceversa tanto l'acqua
quanto le creazioni intellettuali hanno
dato vita dei mercati che ormai valgono
miliardi e miliardi di
euro e ci si avvede anche che acqua e di
idee
pur essendo a portata di mano di tutti
costituiscono e hanno costituito nel
tempo in realtà appannaggio esclusivo di
pochi penso alle grandi società
distributrici di acqua minerale e penso
alle grandi etichette dell'audiovisivo
le major del dell'audio dell'audiovisivo
ma le analogie non finiscono qui perché
in realtà entrambi i mercati proprio
grazie alle nuove tecnologie a
tecnologie naturalmente diverse sono
negli anni diventati assolutamente
globali l'acqua e vian che sgorga a
sulle insorgenti francesi si ritrova
sulle scrivanie dell'intero continente
asiatico così come negli stati uniti
d'america e i film prodotti a hollywood
ormai attraversano attraverso la fibra
ottica
gli oceani e finiscono dentro le nostre
dentro le nostre le nostre case
e sempre per stare alle analogie tra
l'acqua e le creazioni intellettuali ce
n'è un'altra drammaticamente importante
un giro dentro un supermercato e un giro
dentro uno store una libreria o
piuttosto un negozio di cd e dvd cosa ci
racconta ci racconta che in realtà ormai
quello che conta di più è la confezione
e packaging e il marketing che scegliamo
un prodotto che si tratti di una
bottiglia di acqua minerale o che
viceversa si tratti di un contenuto
creativo molto e soprattutto sulla base
di come quel prodotto viene confezionato
ci viene ci viene proposto ci lasciamo
abbagliare dalla forma e mi vengono in
mente pensando a questa analogia le
parole di uno dei primi libri di andrea
camilleri che appunto era la forma
dell'acqua
c'è un passo in cui uno dei personaggi
dice che fai e l'altro risponde
qual è la forma dell'acqua ma l'acqua
non ha forma piglia la forma che gli
viene che gli viene data è la confezione
in realtà che è la scommessa principale
di chi vende di chi vende
l'acqua minerale con la bottiglia e con
la pubblicità che ci convincono ad
acquistarla così esattamente come accade
per la più parte delle creazioni delle
creazioni delle creazioni intellettuali
e allora se ci sono così tante analogie
l'esercizio che ho fatto e l'esercizio
che vi propongo per tranquillizzarvi
come dire condivido il fatto che mancano
al verde cinque minuti e 53 secondi e
che poi il rosso lascia poco spazio in
più per per concludere la mia idea è
semplicemente quella di pensare cosa
accadrebbe domani mattina se attraverso
i rubinetti attraverso le condutture
idriche i rubinetti delle nostre
abitazioni noi potessimo ricevere
direttamente dentro casa le acque
minerali che oggi dobbiamo andare a
comprare al al supermercato
cosa sa cosa accadrebbe come cambierebbe
il nostro modo è il nostro rapporto con
l'acqua minerale da dire che è piuttosto
facile prevedere che in pochi
continueremo andare al supermercato a
pagare il prezzo elevato e soprattutto a
incollarci il pacco dell'acqua minerale
che un buon numero di noi sarebbe
disponibile a pagare un prezzo per veder
sgorgare l'acqua minerale diversamente
direttamente dal suo rubinetto e che
naturalmente quel prezzo
se lo immaginerebbe più basso rispetto
al prezzo che abbiamo pagato sino a oggi
a comprare l'acqua minerale al
supermercato e che inesorabilmente
qualcuno i creativi e i furbi non
mancano da nessuna parte proverebbe ad
attaccarsi direttamente alle tubature di
qualcun altro
e a spillare dell'acqua minerale non
pagando niente e portando a casa
l'acqua frizzante che ieri magari non
andava nemmeno a comprare al
supermercato
ecco se ci pensate questo è esattamente
quello che sta accadendo con la
digitalizzazione nei processi di
circolazione dei contenuti dei contenuti
creativi
qualcuno ha in realtà pochi oggi
continuano andare dal giornalaio in
edicola a comprare il giornale al cinema
a vedere il film o a noleggiare un
un un dvd alcuni per la verità non non
tantissimi scaricano i contenuti
creativi dei pochi servizi legali in
questo momento disponibili e alcuni
forse molti forse troppi
evidentemente si attaccano così come
farebbero alle condutture idriche alla
rete internet e scaricano i contenuti
senza pagare il relativo prezzo e quindi
l'analogia tra l'acqua la circolazione
dell'acqua minerale e la proprietà
intellettuale e forte anche in una
dimensione è dinamica siamo di fronte ad
una rivoluzione di portata epocale
esattamente come sarebbe rivoluzionaria
l'idea di veder sgorgare l'acqua
minerale con tanto di bollicine
direttamente dal rubinetto di rubinetto
di casa poi bisognerebbe governare le
bollicine nel bagno se si sceglie di
utilizzarne una in in particolare e
quindi il tema è cosa deve fare cosa può
fare lo stato di fronte ad un fenomeno i
governi di tutto il mondo di fronte ad
un fenomeno tanto rivoluzionario la mia
idea o perlomeno la mia idea della
lezione dell'acqua la mia intuizione
sulla lezione dell'acqua e che in un
contesto di questo genere
il ruolo dello stato non possa che
essere quello di arbitro tra il giusto
equo diritto a che il creatore di una
qualsiasi opera dell'ingegno riceva una
remunerazione per il suo sforzo creativo
ed in particolare per la condivisione di
questo sforzo creativo nella nella
comunità e che naturalmente e gli utenti
a loro volta possano davvero beneficiare
dello sforzo creativo altrui
però in nel rendersi arbitro di questo
scambio
la lezione dell'acqua ci dice che in
realtà i governi di tutto il mondo cosa
che sempre più raramente purtroppo
accade dovrebbero guardare alle
creazioni intellettuali come ad un bene
che non ha soltanto un valore economico
ma che è esattamente come l'acqua ha un
valore sociale e democratico diverso
completamente diverso dagli altri beni
giuridici economici quindi non è
possibile o non dovrebbe essere
possibile imporre in maniera tanto
prepotente una privativa sulle idee
esattamente come non è possibile non
dovrebbe essere possibile imporre
privative troppo forti sulla
distribuzione dell'acqua minerale sarà
anche un bene potrà anche essere di
qualcuno sarà anche vero che il
risultato dello sforzo creativo di
qualcuno ma la circolazione di quel bene
non è solo un fatto di soldi è un fatto
che ha un impatto mostruoso
sull'esistenza di ciascuno di ciascuno
di noi
e allora qui siamo all'ultimo minuto del
verde e quindi anche alla fine di questa
chiacchierata è quello che io mi e mi mi
chiedo nel prendere atto che ovunque
nell'industria dei contenuti così come
nei governi li è invece una resistenza
straordinaria nel governare in modo
illuminato il futuro della circolazione
delle idee e delle creazioni
intellettuali quello che io mi chiedo è
è possibile che il web che è il più
grande mercato nella storia dell'umanità
è un mercato che si avvia contare tre
miliardi di persone in tutto il mondo
non basti davvero a soddisfare le
esigenze e gli interessi dei produttori
di contenuti e degli autori è possibile
che non esistano modelli di business
capaci di garantire alla comunità
globale l'accesso all'informazione e
alla cultura garantendo al tempo stesso
agli autori e agli inventori ai
produttori di contenuti la possibilità
di guadagnare quanto è loro necessario
per continuare a produrre è di nuovo in
intelletto ingegno e opere utili per
tutti quanti per tutti quanti noi siamo
entrati nel rosso è il momento dei il
momento dei saluti e quello dei
ringraziamenti ma prima è il momento
della condivisione della intuizione
posto che questo era
è il tema questo è il tema di questo di
questo ted
la mia sensazione è che in realtà serva
solo ed esclusivamente un nuovo patto
sociale nel quale gli stati dovrebbero
farsi promotori e garanti persi severi
senza lasciarsi tirare però dalla
giacchetta da nessun tipo di interesse
politico ed economico di questo scambio
di utilità quello che l'autore è
l'inventore mette a disposizione della
collettività e la remunerazione che il
singolo garantisce all'inventore
all'inventore stesso e allora il
messaggio nella bottiglia e l'auspicio
che condividendo con voi questa
intuizione vorrei affidare alle correnti
della rete e che nel mercato della
proprietà intellettuale si possa presto
assistere ad uno stemperamento dei toni
che quelli che oggi sembrano acerrimi
nemici i produttori gli autori gli
inventori e i fruitori di informazione e
cultura possano riscoprirci per quello
che sono davvero cioè appartenenti ad
una stessa ed identica ed identica
comunità studiare la lezione dell'acqua
farne tesoro per governare la proprietà
intellettuale e questa in straordinaria
sintesi perché è tra un minuto e 25
secondi mi dovrò fermare ma forse lo
farò prima la riflessione che lascio al
vaglio della comunità scientifica perché
come dire il ted serve a far rimbalzare
lontano anche da qui questa questa come
tutte le altre idee agli addetti ai
lavori ai legislatori ei governi panta
rei e naturalmente vi auguro buona
prosecuzione auguro buona fortuna al
futuro e attraverso il futuro auguro
buona fortuna a noi stessi